et c'est merci la parole est à monsieur
olivier dassault merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances nos artisans tpe et pme qui
représentent 90 % des entrepreneurs
français sont terriblement déçu malgré
le cce les charges restent trop élevés
leur taux d'imposition est l'un des plus
hauts d'europe à cause des seuils et des
normes trop rigide ces entreprises
n'osent pas créer de nouveaux emplois
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas cessé durant ce
quinquennat d'alourdir l'addition
les chiffres sont têtus mais ils sont là
la france sont au ralenti sa croissance
vivote bien en dessous de celle de nos
voisins
notre nation paie très cher trop cher
votre politique économique trop timide
le groupe des républicains se réjouit
néanmoins que la loi égalité réelle
permettent de réserver une part des
marchés publics d'outre-mer à leurs pme
mais pourquoi ne pas élargir élargir son
application à l'ensemble de notre
territoire national depuis 2012
votre majorité on parle là le souhaite
mais n'ose pas dommage pour nos tpe pme
qui ont du mal à accéder commande
publique
malgré une réforme visant à simplifier à
réorganiser et à donner plus de
transparence
en fait elle alourdit le travail des
communes qui doivent se justifier sans
pour autant privilégier les
entrepreneurs locaux pire encore il est
demandé aux volontaires plus de
paperasse plus expertise en un mot plus
d'argent dépensé quel prix à payer pour
participer à la loterie des marchés
publics non monsieur le ministre il n'y
a pas de honte à mettre en avant
la préférence territoriale au contraire
à la clé ce sont des emplois locaux de
la croissance locale à potter économique
essentiel pour les territoires et leurs
aménagements nous artisans entrepreneurs
exige des mesures réalistes pragmatiques
de bon sens et de saine gestion que
votre logiciel n'a pas su proposer d'y
défendre
alors monsieur le ministre allez vous
réagir
et si oui comment merci monsieur
dassault la parole et à monsieur
christian eckert
secrétaire d'état chargé du budget et
des comptes publics merci monsieur le
président il vous plait d'amis je vois
qu'on approche de la fin de cette séance
du jour même monsieur le député d'assaut
votre plaidoyer pour les pme tpe est
saisissant mais je reconnais bien là on
vous la capacité de maîtriser l'ensemble
des panels des outils économiques depuis
les plus petites entreprises jusqu'aux
plus prestigieuses
certains suggéraient que notre collègue
le drian vous répondent mais je voudrais
plutôt vous dire quelles sont les
mesures qui ont été prises par ce
gouvernement ce gouvernement mesdames et
messieurs il a fait en sorte qu'il n'y
ait plus de contrats de la commande
publique
excluant d'office les pme c'est ainsi
1,5 milliard d'euros qui ne viendrez me
il n'ya plus d'élimination des pme au
stade de l'analyse des candidatures
puisque désormais l'exigence de chiffre
d'affaires ne peut plus dépasser deux
fois la valeur estimée assurez vous
madame ça va s'arrêter ça ça va bien se
passer
très bien se passer alors vous suggérez
vous suggérez monsieur le député
d'étendre une disposition qui a été
adopté dans la loi nous y sommes et
gardez vos munitions députés pour être
très précis avec vous cette disposition
pose un certain nombre de problèmes
constitutionnels par rapport à l'égalité
de traitement dans les marchés publics
et ne sauraient en l'état être
reproduite en tout cas le gouvernement a
parfaitement conscience et il a pris les
mesures pour ouvrir les marchés publics
aux petites et moyennes entreprises
comme aux plus grosses merci m